what's going on today
yeah it's already kind of warm
especially wearing all this armor
so what's going on you know these people
over here no okay are you just kind of
watching the show yeah I've
previous uh Silent Witness chairman and
so I'm always curious about what's going
on okay
yeah it's a little traffic stop thing
they're just trying to sort through
something so
a lot of response well it was just kind
of a multi-jurisdictional thing and uh
just kind of came out across a bunch of
different areas so that's all yeah we're
just trying to figure out what's going
on so you don't know any of these people
though
a little hard of hearing I'm sorry you
don't know any of these people though
Hey Jake
okay
well cool yeah it looks like they're
probably wrapping up what's going on
right now
so what's your name sir
what's your first name just uh Curious
and nosy what what's your first name
Carl Carl I'm Ryan well it's nice to
meet you Carl so you used to do Silent
Witness she said yeah I used to up until
about two years ago when the chairman of
Silent Witness so we usually found out
later what was going on okay well cool
only only nosy that's all
yeah this ain't much and it's definitely
not anything that affects the security
of Flagstaff so I think we're good
thanks sir
[Music]
foreign
truck
going in the trailer
let's get everyone out of the car now
everyone out of the car
[Music]
they're taking them back
no
come with me
I'll come start walking back there they
don't need to go on a handcuffs
go ahead come right here for me come
over by this girl
stay right there
just do me a favor keep your hands out
of your pockets for me all right
do you guys have names
I'm Deputy Mitchell
you want to tell me your name or
just so I know what I'm talking to okay
this is uh this one in the dark room
there's no one in the trailer
foreign
[Music]
just keep your hands out of your pockets
for me okay
any other ID
nothing you don't have ID cards
how old are you 14. how old are you here
old are you
okay
well we're gonna identify each and
everything
[Music]
okay
ma'am can you keep your hand out of your
pockets thank you
all right I understand it's just a
safety thing
foreign
[Music]
put your phones up on the on the vehicle
here
go ahead and put your phones up on the
vehicle thank you all right hey do you
have a phone cell phone yeah that's not
right is it you don't have a cell phone
start with me okay okay not a problem
all right do we have to like put them
out there yes ma'am we're doing an
investigation right now and I'm not
going to have you uh have a phone in
front of me okay
you'll have it right and get yourself
afterwards okay
so instead of playing games let's just
put them there like I just asked him to
all right
so I got your ID correct okay
first
class
make sure it's clear
[Music]
just let you guys know if you provide
false information that can be charged so
we're just giving you a warning now all
right
your first name your middle name and
Alaskan do you have a middle name that's
okay and your date of birth
and does everyone have water anyone like
eating
water or anything
okay we'll do that as soon as our
investigation is done here okay why
children are being transported in a
vehicle we're getting calls about uh
hands sticking out of a vehicle out of
the trailer
um so that is why we're contacting you
guys because it is unsafe for children
to be riding in a trailer they're not
properly seat belted and uh we need to
do an investigation and figure out
what's going on okay
if you have any questions
no ma'am
right now we're just we're just
investigating
at this point he's detained right now
I don't know
okay I understand that but like he said
once we do our investigation we can
figure this out but we just need you
guys to give us your names and stuff
no ma'am no you're not going to decide
to outcome of this we will decide and
we'll let you know how everything's
gonna happen here okay
sound okay
thank you
and uh
all right
I'm gonna have you put your name below
that line first name middle last name
date of birth that's okay we just uh we
just need a full name for everyone
[Music]
are you able to write your first name
and last name all right perfect
start a new page so you have a
writer
no Arizona state law says video
recording us within eight feet I believe
it is right now yeah eight feet of us is
against the law now
when they're just passed by the
governor's office
juvenile
they have to be properly strapped in
got it all right thank you
[Music]
the car
and do we have a way to contact them all
did it
really well for committed glass
foreign
nowhere
[Music]
so do me a favor when I talk to you I'll
talk to you when I talk to someone else
don't answer for them unless you are
legal guardian of them and you have a
legal privileged answers for them okay
oh I they have no reason to be afraid of
me the only reason I've had to keep
addressing you is because you keep
stepping in and I need to be able to
talk to everyone
okay well in what city or state was that
in
okay well you're in Flagstaff Arizona
right now
um so what we will treat you uh we're
just trying to happen we are just trying
to figure this out right now what is
going on okay it is not normal practice
for people to be transported in a
trailer
okay all right
let's let's go ahead and start
separating and uh let's get the
juveniles the adult separated versus the
juvenile so they quit talking so let me
get those ideas and verify Pages real
quick okay
he's gonna verify the 2739s and then
we're going to separate adults and doom
now
your nail
to the one in the red dress he's talking
to is basically the ring leader
basically
from what I'm getting
money
right uh you were born in 03 so are you
hungry
go ahead and stay
safe
everything
[Music]
you're okay
we're all recording here everything's uh
foreign
[Music]
I know
foreign
I got it
oh you got it
a preference or just next down the line
um I'll just stay with the name
do you want help interviewing yeah if
people want to kind of pick one and uh
and just start talking about
a question
um
I need one of you guys to come talk to
me okay
[Music]
what's your name
what was that
Dorothea how do you spell that
[Music]
all right Dorothy yeah
and how old are you
14.
well I'm Deputy Mitchell okay I'm with
the sheriff's office I just want to
figure out what's going on here okay
so where were you guys headed to
I actually don't need to know
you don't know for sure how long have
you been in Flagstaff
a couple hours
and where were you guys coming from
Colorado City
is that where you guys live at
where you live
[Music]
and are these your parents or
do your parents still in Colorado City
one of them which one
mom and you don't know where she is
do you need any medical attention were
you hurt at all
no okay
and where were you writing
in in the trucker and the cat
in the trail
and who was riding with you
um
you didn't know where you guys were
going to you were just riding
you got invited to come who invited you
your friends are are they here or okay
and where did they invite you to come
here they just said you're going on the
trip yeah okay
and how long have you known these
friends for
you can guess
[Music]
what do your parents know each other
foreign
[Music]
like a flower garden
ing
[Music]
cool all right okay